Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to cuphead okay, so this is the end of it
I think I'm not 100% sure, "one hell of a time" indeedy-do it is indeedy-do it is.
"Well well well look how far you've come
Not only did you bust up my good-for-nothing Lackey king dice,
But I see you've got my soul contracts as agreed, hand 'em over and join my team!"
...NO! No I won't - whoa
"Welching on me just like all the others, eh? I'll teach you for backing out of a deal.
Have at  you!" Alright, fine then whatever, have at YOU, sir,
Mister devil if that is your name. Uh oh
This is probably gonna be tough... as hell... ha get it. (Yes Mark we get it) Uh Oh that's whoa I didn't know that hurt too okay
Whoa oh boy, this is gonna be a doozy oh boy
Oh boy the animation team really went to town on this one. Oh, Nellie Wellie
Okay, wellie Nellie
Oh boi Bellie bellie
alright
That's not good Whoaaaahhhh
Yep, not even close not even close
Alright here we go
Miss me oh, wee oh whoa spaghetti spaghetti junction. Oh, that's a new one
I've got the slappa you can't defeat my ow you can totally defeat my slappa I'm sorry
It's absolutely absolutely you can you can 100% defeat slappa, hup  boink! Oh?
You can't even touch the arms. Well. That's gonna be that's gonna be a tit sprinkle
*Intense preparation of the slappa*
oh shit what was I doing I wasn't e-
I was just spacing out there like taking in the scenery like I was just I was literally just looking at everything else being
Like man, this is really pretty all this is really well animated
It's just gotta admit the detail in the background and hell is like well that's new okay. I don't like this
Oh, nope like that not oh boy. Yep like that a whole lot of not. Holy shit. I don't like that
All right
Let's see what this will do. Probably nothingm whole lot of nothing. At least it gives me an opportunity to hit them with it
That's awfully nice of him oh
shit shit
SHIT
Ohh shit
Oh boy, oh boy
That's not good - AYY! W- I hate that. Go? Well alrighty then I'll go I guess
Well hi! Hello Devil!
Oh, that's not good. Oh, that's
Yeesh oh - pff
Okay, ah
Really really really really really really really really. Oh really
Wow
Oh boy, okay. I got this.
Really? (Yes really Mark.) uh frick, I feel like that's my only commentary to say this
particular encounter is really really really
Really, oh really that hit me. Oh yeah sure okay, I believe you
Well that that definitely got me that really got me that that one really that one really with me
This is gonna be a dooooozy
Okay, sorry. I'm not saying anything because I'm just concentrating so hard on this
Okay, well you know I'm gonna go - Oh what that hurt me? Really?
Standing there when he did that hurt me really oh boy. Well you know what you are a sack of-
You are a piece of work young man
You are a real piece of work. Whoa hey. I don't like that
That's a bomb? Oh slappa! Slappa bomb! Slappa batta bomb! Slappa bomb bat - oh boy.
Uhhh, well, I
Panicked and died totally of my own volition totally. That was, just me just me nothing happened. I was just scared ah
banca Wonka Danka oh
Awww I had the - shit okay alright okay phase 2 phase 2 don't get in the way of the skeleton when he goes down
Stay here in hell. Oh boy. That's scawy
Whoa okay kill that bomb bat right away. That's the answer to that question. Oh that conundrum
*various whoas and uhhs*
Alright WHOA what did I do?
He's angry he's angry HE'S MAD
He's very mad
There - Oh he's a grumpy Gus I don't know what that's all about that's that's peculiar well
I'm dead, so it doesn't really matter what it is. Hey, but I'm getting close. I guess but still feels very far
very far. Very close, but very far. Whoa whoa I've forgotten how to parry slap whoa I completely forgot how to parry  slap oh
Okay, all right. Well here with phase 2 at 3l so that's a good thing that I enjoy
Oh shit, I wasn't even paying attention that was completely stupid ah fuck again. Oh no oh no oh no. Oh boy
I really boned my whole lead there. That was just
ridiculously stupid of me
Oh boy. Oh well alright then
Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy.
What is that all about? What is that all about? I don't like that. I don't like that. I don't like that
I don't like that. I don't like that. I don't like that. I know I'm not saving my super
I should save my super in the second phase in this phase. It's good because it helps me the
The little assholes if they walk in the corners it can help alleviate that but, for the other one
I should definitely save my super for when it's - okay well
I should save my super for when it's really necessary because
When he's a big head he I'm definitely gonna be able to hit him
I should definitely save it for that phase if anything. Here definitely just shield up because it's like an extra buffer
Like there. He was in the corner, and if I hadn't had that it would have been bad for me
Okay, here we go, here we go, here we go phase two phase two phase two. I'm goin. I'm goin. I'm goin
Okay, so this is where I got to save up my super
I can't I can't spend it on the stupidity of the other one. I'm watching you, baby
There we go there we go there we go there we go there we go there we go there we go
there we go there we go there we go. Oh, no where you going ooh
That's a big boy super ready oh
Shit wasn't paying attention, but I got it anyway. I'm getting it Oh full damage full damage
I didn't get the other parry slap, but that's okay yah yah yah yah yah, yah
I said I should have saved it for this phase, but I guess I didn't do that might have forgotten all about it
Whoa
How did I avoid that damage? I will never know I will never ever
There we go that's my end is my end. This is end - ahh
shit ticks
oh
Man that one is hard if I need to save
The super for that phase because I can't be in there long
I I if I had the super then I would have cut that phase down
And I wouldn't have been subjected to the horrors that I experienced Oh
No oh no oh no, that's you know I can't if I don't go into the next phase with full health, I'm dead
I mean, I'll try if I get close, but, whatever. Oh wow okay
This is oh boy going into phase 2 with one health that's kind of the opposite of what I was hoping for oh well
Here we go I got this super waiting for me. Which is awfully nice
Whoa shit, that's scary
There we go alright. It's gonna get here gonna use this
I've only got one health oh
shit almost lost it oh
Oh, oh
Oh jeez, did that guy die?
Wow okay I didn't even know they could die like that. Oh, wow okay? Oh, No how close was I?
Not as close as I could be to get angry if I hadn't lost the health in the first round
Two health in the first round which was stupid. This is like Easy Street. This shouldn't cause any trouble
Oh, you know what I realized what what gun might be better is the spread shot. I'm gonna try to change weapons good god.
Oof. I've almost got this. I'm very close to getting it
I just need to I I don't think the charged shot is the right ability I think the spread shot either that or,
Either that or the lobber would be good. Let me try the lobber. Oh, I got this alright come on no no
Ah shit well
I can't parry for craps, so it doesn't change anything. I don't know if the lobber is gonna be the best one that seems like a
An unfortunately weird one
Ah shit
All right, that's definitely not not good. Hang on I'm gonna go back. I'm gonna get the spread
Ahh there you go. How do you like that spread in your face? Huh hey you like it devil, baby?
You like it you like it you like it. Oh I bet you like it. Oh you love it
Oh you love it. Oh shit. Oh, how did I dodge that? I don't know
Something tells me the spreads on my - whelp sh-goddammit I just had to open my big
flip flappin flapjacker
Didn't I? I just had to yap on about how oh this is the one this is the good stuff
This is really givin him, the one fer
Hey, how's it going there?
All right well there he is okay there I go all right
Whoo all right two health not bad
If I can get through this next part okay
cuz this is this really where it makes a difference cuz it's just me whaling on him like non-stop, right?
Well what whoa whoa what the hell whoa?
I forgot hit down right bumper to make me me stick. Holy shit. That was so stupid of me. Oh god
That was stupid okay. I got my super. I know I'm just waiting for the next next one
Here we go
Okay, whoa oh
Oh, oh, oh he's crying whoa whoa miss that one. Why are you crying, buddy? Oh?
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!!
Spread was the key spread was the key spread was the key holy shit.
Whoooooo oh Nellie
One health left Wow wowie Zowie wowie Zowie Wow A minus not bad!
Not bad not bad!
Not bad at all just about 30 minutes on that fight.
"The brothers had triumphed over the demon forcing him to finally give up/
We shall accept your surrender devil, Cuphead laughed, but we're not done just yet.
And with that Cuphead and Mugman destroyed all the soul contracts releasing inkwell Isles residents from eternal servitude to the devil
Gosh, I can't wait to tell everybody, Cuphead said. The boys set off for home and at top speed. Come on, last
One there's a leaky cup! Mugman teased as they ran.
Once on the brothers gathered everyone together.
You're all free of the devil's debt! Cuphead announced. And that fiend won't bother us ever again
Mugman added. The elder kettle was literally brimming with pride as everyone began to cheer
Let'd hear it for Cuphead and Mugman!
Hip-hip-hurrah! Hip-hip-hurrah!
Even though they beat the shit out of all of us. "As an all-day celebration began the brothers promise to never wander into trouble again
And they didn't until the next time of course, but that is another story."
Oh that was beautiful. Oh that was beautiful. I love that so much God the passion that went into that game oh
I can't say anything that hasn't already been said about this game, but that was
Absolutely wonderful. "Our sincere appreciation to the members of our team who loyalty and creative endeavor made this possible production Chad and Jared Moldenhauer
You guys are awesome, and you guys are awesome for watching. Thank you everybody for sticking with me through this
I know I'm not the best Cuphead player, but hey
I told you I was good at shmups. I ain't the Boris in the world so that was a lot of fun
I loved that it was really really cool. I had a great time playing it from beginning to end oh, man
That was so much fun
I can't imagine the amount of work that went into each and every frame of that because all that was hand hand drawn hand
Animated turning a game into an experience that was beyond anything that I've ever seen before
totally unique completely original and a challenge and just an all-around blast
So thank you everybody somebody for watching. I'm gonna stick around to the end of the credits
Just to see if there's anything at the end of that
I hope for a sequel to this game support the release if you like this game
And you haven't bought it yet buy it because it's such a delightful thing and you just want to see more stuff like this
Forget all the triple-a like yearly release
Bullshit get more things like this because like games are developed by what people buy
And if everyone's buying the triple-a stuff, that's great
But it's just all this money put into a sink that has no passion into it whereas things like this have so much passion
Dripping through every single second of the game love it love it
Love it to death, love it a million times, so I'm gonna get to the end and then I'm gonna say goodbye
Oh, they have their own fans. Ah they don't
answer alright
What was that? Oh, what did I miss?
Did I just miss something all right? Well anyway that is cuphead. Thank you again everybody for watching
There was something at the end there  (it says this is the end there is no more or is there hahahah)
But there will be another video probably on YouTube that outlines whatever that was so thank you everybody so much for watching
Let's all get a sequel made and as always I will see you in the next video.
Ba-Bye!